So the original running time here was O(nV) since the V was this value here and now
since we scaled it down using this factor here what we now have to do is we have
to replace V by V/V/n(1-c), which is the same as O(n²1/1-c), which is the same as this one here.
Now, of course, in order to be very correct here, we have to constraint c so that it cannot be 1;
otherwise, this running time here would be undefined--well, that's okay.
As you will soon see that actually makes quite a lot of sense.
So you've seen that we now have made the running time independent of V
and that is of course a very cool thing because V originally was what could make this algorithm
run in exponential time and now we can use this factor 1-c here to control the running time.
So the running time will, of course, again become exponential if c becomes very close to 1,
but it will be polynomial if for example we set c to 0
and something in between when we set c to other values.
Now, I still haven't told you what the c here is going to be about, but we'll soon figure that out.